la série en 10 épisodes damer monstre
l'histoire de Jeffrey Dahmer ce sont les
tunnels
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il s'en rappelle une émission sur une
radio publique mais là où quelqu'un a
passé je pense au moins trois quatre
minutes c'est très loin radio 3-4
minutes à faire tout un sketch une
satire en disant on a hâte que j'ai 28
ans pour dire qu'enfin vous baiser avec
des mecs parce qu'on sait tous depuis le
début il y a vous qui êtes pas con et
tout un sketch comme ça pendant trois
quatre minutes et je dis tellement
choqué mais vraiment et en fait le gars
je vais les fracasser j'ai fracassé j'ai
dit à la différence entre vous et moi
vous êtes payés pour défoncer les gens
et vous avez besoin de faire une fiche
pour sortir votre merde moi j'ai pas
besoin de faire une fiche pour vous
exploser en 5 minutes et donc là je vais
réveiller le gars directement ça vous
lui dites à l'antenne ou après
l'émission
pour le coup mais parce que au bout d'un
moment les gens ont l'impression que
parce que vous êtes connu parce que vous
êtes en une servi en interview vous
devez aussi recevoir ce déversement de
merde parce qu'il y a pas d'autres mots
parce que simplement si vous répondez
vous êtes quelqu'un de prétentieux et
tout mais vous dites juste mais stop en
fait dans la vie le mec me parle comme
ça je lui mets une droite
c'est que on peut faire une interview
être un bon journaliste sur une
interview sans rentrer dans les détails
de la vie privée ils sont imposés
imposés de raconter des choses de sa vie
pas forcément un journaliste il parle
d'un chroniqueur
après tu vas dans une radio il y a un
papier humoristique qui casse un peu bah
tu acceptes le truc
[Musique]
justement durée de l'émission qui alors
vous
dit qui a qui croit le petit Maxime qui
y croit déjà durer l'émission est-ce que
tu sais c'est combien de temps bien sûr
cette prime pour ça humaine pourquoi
c'est aussi short parce que il y a la
Coupe du monde donc ils ont voulu faire
un truc hyper condensé pour une
formation en accéléré avec le même
principe une quotidienne un peu plus
longue de 45 minutes sans plateau c'est
un pari éditorial c'est aussi parce que
ils essayent d'être dans la case de
famille nombreuse
samedi donc c'est un vrai Paris tout en
images avec 17h20 avec une voix offerte
le programme c'est le samedi à la
quotidienne quotidienne tous les jours
pour le moment effectivement sur parrain
marraine on serait sur du Céline Dion
voilà et en parrain voilà il y a Kylie
Minogue aussi qui rentre dedans mais
pour l'instant c'est des négociations
pour l'instant il les auraient pas moi
ma star academa je rappelle que energy
12 on leur a fait bonjour à travers un
écran salut Céline elle était au Canada
ça pour l'instant on en est là ils vont
nous faire une énergie musicale
message pendant deux heures elle avait
arrivée à je suis désolé Fighters non
non ça va être plus à chier moi le seul
truc non mais c'est la vérité au qu'on
se le dise qu'on se connaît très bonne
en imitation
quoi parce que vous avez vu comment
c'est court ils font ils font cette
prime donc même il croit pas parce que
si ça marche sur une saison 2 sur les
anciens
la série on disait épisode dame heureuse
toi l'histoire de Jeffrey Dahmer une
affaire qui a bouleversé toute
l'Amérique dans les années 90
entre 1978 et 1991 Jeffrey Dahmer va
droguer violer tuer en allant même
parfois jusqu'à dévorer 17 victimes
c'était juste la condamné ce tueur en
série à 957 ans de prison 30 ans plus
tard l'affaire passionne avec 197,2
millions de vues en une semaine cette
série phénomène s'impose comme le plus
gros succès Netflix de tous les temps
manger le sandwich et ce n'est pas tout
sur Internet les effets personnels du
cannibale de Milwaukee se revendent à
prix d'or une lettre de son père à 2500
dollars sa Bible à 5000 dollars mais
surtout sa père de lunettes
emblématiques à 150000 dollars un
engouement quelque peu morbi qui a
réalisé la douleur des familles des
victimes et notamment de Rita isbelle
incarnés dans la série au moment du
procès je trouve que Netflix aurait dû
nous demander cela nous dérangeait ou ce
que nous ressentions ils ne m'ont rien
demandé ils ont juste fait leur série
moi je suis vous choqué oui qu'on fasse
commerce de ça de la mort effectivement
et des familles des victimes en revanche
quand tu dis c'est normal que ce soit
médiatisé qui deviennent qui soit adulte
ouais non il est pasteur il est pas
adulé on y va parce que c'est de la
curiosité
de garçon comme des filles de plus de
demandes en mariage dans les prisons et
Charles Manson le célèbre tueur en série
qui a fait assassiner Sharon take la
femme de Polanski et 9 autres personnes
avec elle et bien il reçoit jusqu'à la
fin il a reçu des demandes de mariage
les visiteuses en prison venez le voir
lui
est-ce que quelqu'un croit un petit peu
surnaturel sur la table ah tu crois toi
mais c'est ma vie moi je suis bourré de
paranormal de surnaturel j'ai des codes
j'ai des je reçois des messages et tout
mais c'est pas une blague c'est vrai
j'ai fait des décorations j'ai qui mon
âme a quitté mon corps j'en ai fait
trois dans ma vie ouais et à côté de
vous évidemment il y a Monsieur
cartésien c'est pas que j'y crois pas
c'est que c'est toujours compliqué de
discuter de ça parce qu'il y a plein de
gens ici j'imagine qu'ils croient
terriblement à ça la vie après la mort
la voyance etc les médias avec ça moi
perso j'y crois pas mais on s'en fout ce
que je veux dire c'est que j'ai fait des
dizaines des dizaines d'expérience
notamment pendant 5 ans sur TF1 dans une
émission il y a pas photo on avait
beaucoup on a fait d'écriture
automatique on a fait exprès je n'y ai
personne ne m'a jamais bluffé et même je
vais te dire très souvent c'était
souvent des charlatans et que moi je
passe mon temps à militer pour que si
vous croyez à tout ça bah allez-y et
puis ils ont tous vous avez tous une
expérience de vous dire mais le mec m'a
dit exactement le prénom de mon père ou
de mon grand-père ou de ce qui nous est
arrivé un truc que personne savait tout
le monde vous dit toujours ça sauf ceux
qui n'y croient pas ce qui est assez
marrant d'ailleurs et en fait j'ai
jamais été scotchée
de charlatanisme auprès de gens qui sont
plutôt faibles psychologiquement pour
certains qu'on vit d'entendre des choses
qu'on a envie qu'on leur dise des trucs
et je vous laisserai vendre votre salade
non non justement je voudrais en parler
de Benoît parce que avant l'émission
notamment à Victoria parce que
non mais c'est surtout que en fait je ne
suis pas étonné de ce que vous avez dit
d'ailleurs dans ce que j'ai marqué sur
vous c'est à peu près ça c'est-à-dire
que vous vous avez vraiment une énergie
particulière et alors de tous les Chron
il y en a quelques uns qui ont vraiment
une belle énergie ou une force ou une
protection mais alors vous vous êtes
vraiment à part ah oui c'est à dire vous
voyez une carrière alors au-delà de ça
c'est à dire que déjà de toute façon
c'est un garçon qui va vraiment réussir
mais c'est pas que ça c'est à dire que
vous êtes hyper
ultra protégé j'ai rarement vu ça il va
y avoir très très gros bouleversement
votre vie donc très peu de temps et
c'est quelque chose vraiment d'inatoires
qui va venir à vous et vous allez
apparemment accepter cette opportunité
et à partir de là vous allez décoller
mais c'est très très
vite tout ce que vous allez faire vous
allez le réussir oh merci il va
continuer à réussir
il va peut-être même avoir un autre
enfant d'ici trois ans mon Dieu je suis
enceinte oui voilà c'est ça
il va avoir un an pour Cyril Hanouna
peut-être quelque chose à faire entre
vous pour avoir un enfant oui
parce que
je suis très embêtant vous pensez que
Cyril et j'aime la vie comme on dit je
pense je pense que si vous l'invitez
ce sera possible
je suis complètement perdu